it's genuinely quite stressful this is a
lariat
[Music]
I'm an example of what it looks like
when support and love is poured into
someone mom down love you so much
[Applause]
thank you for teaching me that God is
always leaning always has been leaning
in my direction I want to dedicate this
to to my grandmother who has been in my
my ear my entire life telling me that if
I first I don't succeed try try again
that I could do anything I put my mind
to always always pushing me to think
positively and I know that I would not
be here without her if you have a dream
fight for it there's a discipline for
passion and it's not about how many
times you get rejected or buts you fall
down or you're beaten up it's about how
many times you stand up and are brave
and you keep on going thank you
I think about what it would have been
like to tell little Bubba Romney that
one day this might happen to him and I
think his curly-haired little mind would
be blown that kid was he was struggling
with his identity trying to figure
himself out and I think to anyone
struggling with theirs and trying to
discover their voice listen we made a
foam about a gay man an immigrant who
lived his life just unapologetically
himself and the fact that I'm
celebrating him and this story with you
tonight is is proof that we're longing
for for stories like this my kids are
watching well if you're not then we'll
kind of well done
sort of hope you are this is not gonna
happen again and and any little girl who
was but who's practicing their speech on
the telly you never know and when I I
used to work as a cleaner and I loved
that job I did spend quite a lot of my
time imagining it so please wrap up
right okay and thank you the 2020
presidential election is around the
corner let's all mobilize
let's all be in the right side of
history make the moral choice between
love versus hate let's do the right
thing you know I had to get that in
there
[Applause]
[Music]
you